when you watched c-span do you want to
know more about the democratic process
and its players then order the c-span US
Congress handbook
it's colossi of legislative terms helps
clarify political language like
committee of the whole
continuing resolution and markup the
c-span US congress handbook is a must
for viewers who want a quick easy
reference guide to the names and faces
on Capitol Hill
it contains valuable information on
members of the House and Senate brief
biographies of the nine Supreme Court
justices tips on writing your
Congressman and a special section about
c-span and its viewer services for your
copy send a check or money order for 695
to c-span US Congress handbook 400 North
Capitol Street Northwest suite 650
Washington DC the zip code is 2 0 0 0 1
[Music]
this afternoon at the Soviet embassy
here in Washington Soviet President
Gorbachev hosted the luncheon about 60
persons attended including the Reverend
Jesse Jackson former Minnesota
Democratic senator Eugene McCarthy who
ran for president in 1968 the chairman
of the cable news network Ted Turner and
actress Jane Fonda coming up next we
bring you the comments of President
Gorbachev as he stressed the
continuation of reform in the Soviet
Union the need for increased cooperation
with the United States and the
suggestion of a more cautious approach
for the independence movements in
Lithuania and other Baltic states
immediately afterward members of the
audience including former Secretary of
State Henry Kissinger offered toasts and
words of welcome to the Gorbachev's
[Music]
[Applause]
what Omega Spada
what does that make us for that
yeah which is a still previous verse
here who has a blog that Yahtzee yeah
and it's Maxim only my career cutter
available e-soo devotion Tom the ocean
you are a reporter that was to
appreciate yes potato Granada marina is
radiation of Asturias for you
khadiyah Potomac store Takei of
stretcher
Oona's Philippa dogness richer pooja ba
la próxima previous neva cassava
suitable Adnan is but she's a bit it
away visitor he lists but realest
realest Petrovna Scooby oh no Street
it's a little minty regains intellectual
never go see understand to America Eber
the Josiah drawers at Ibaka Canyon a
reported stolen emotions the prescott o
allah drove oil - the nuts illness
swimmy glutes millet me talent me he
nazi-occupied universal Kentucky Anna or
chinchilla lead yes Lee need was more
than she reads what's a team Talentum
yes Lee 4x college initiative oil watch
history that Obispo cui Xia
my such as bushy beard roma you know he
is the only letter washed up with Jeff
talk like you taught us cuz that was
nice Russia stream a more smoke cover
the odorous Quebec more generous
gorillas yet Appa Momo vesemir illusion
yay
nyow dose wash destiny DAC / senior wash
Academy true scooty camellias in a
neutral body
night in Aviana escazu it's this door
Tommy Mulligan becomes new monkey here
is something that we couldn't do for
such a long time that that's possible
humilating it's the video knows but
what's really hope hundred million I
don't let stood watts if not although
one hundred and twenty languages and
that is wrong well we still have to sort
things out about it in our country we
still have sorted it all out not long
before but we understand the main issue
for you to renew for you understanding
our country you lived in our history
that we have decided we cannot continue
to live without our way and that was
decided to mark the Lord you on March
11th in the evening Roger descent on
idealist
well well see if you try to add
something what happens and the day later
I was elected Secretary General of the
Central Committee of the Communist Party
and we had to think we cannot continue
living that way how are we going to live
in naturally flashy boys and from that
day on we began our search even here
those present my colleagues my friends
and perestroika with
by us give us and Judah Kotori it is
important is it that automatically to
have on this crowd people who helped me
of what I saw that striker is gaining
momentum in much as album before that
we've been no family this scale devil
without you
but mainly I knew that any will turn on
your country towards peace
Mosca that dark I can't to say all this
is not similar they keep a scan be
constantly in Romania I you sleep
nevertheless right yeah and if having
you've done with this work over five
years if you had another chance would
you have chosen the same part I am
convinced yeah
then those after five years of our
cereal for dinner eat ATP receive our
neediest the emotions and today is the
peak of our emotions we cannot choose
another path and we cannot turn back
yaniv a trip with navy i shouid i do not
want to be insistent worse than you
think you do end up sure hit you at esa
you interested to know what's happening
in the soviet union
today the computed this moreover people
shoot there are so many people who write
about it thank it would be useful for us
to exchange these years and I told you
present today at least two main
questions have to be answered with light
you have an answer and we'll give our
answer to it first
how would you like to see the Savage and
I will tell you how we would like the
United States to be I want to say when
we have started great changes without
any but yes we have to do it together
what does it mean to be together let's
think about just in - that's my story
whoever sick Kissinger you you you know
and if I want that yeah yeah others cuz
I say something cocky - I guess but you
miss you even even mr. Kissel taste some
what I would like to say he kept you in
conservatory in the spirit of the
impulses that are dictated my life he's
saying that way and I respect him for
that don't match it with me what does it
mean to be together more than superiors
well we can get the formula completely
shocked water shake the moon and do this
this formula is a step forward because
we were enemies
but there was confrontation and what a
confrontation were used to now I think
olya more really we were especially more
mature I evolution the commune tell is
to take into account a novel you which
is essentially showing relations century
and it is astonishing what if you see in
two hours and you have shaken when you
see it when you started many times and
then we parted with the more therefore G
varnish the way it is very important
especially chance that we have today and
I think you have those present here I
know what the right approach is made
with you more at least on this topic
so the key thing I read to quite a lot -
I know
Ludacris there are people here you know
who if a Frankie free budget um Jim
O'Neill Osprey audience I mean and be
thinking visas to the same conclusion as
us we are thinking people to recorded
the most own are not that means we have
to search no record on all those new
approaches understanding and even
confrontation moons to terribly
information let's not give you such
return only in this way Nia in the
middle of the night the race the hands
are said well we are leaving the survey
what to do they don't know what to do
and we don't know what to do with that's
one way of solving problems no yes it's
an approach really private but no matter
where he
and Wilma CMRR he several times measure
but captain only worries about astora
and now within frame of Pierce troika I
say you know measure Y and I also see it
as a very easy to make mistakes and
that's not rushin across the area but
from your own front a shinto partnership
we don't have partnership romantic well
that's what we would like to move you
know professor yeah except earring which
is two years appearance for beautiful
everybody but this same time from
competition then I'm convinced our
nation's can live in peace
right in the home ass
if we don't spoil the situation but yeah
and we could be either strength of these
tendencies or ruler also hit though the
game those familia who has the word and
has influenced many of those are because
right here I think we have to move to
America among our people all the dishes
and presenters are intelligence er idea
all questions store will not show that
was tossed on achievers what natural
supporters who will change moschini
symmetrically began here many people
know it and we know that is relations
you can take me yeah they remember the
war one Clyburn is where we remember and
he is a man who has done much to live a
true understanding between our people
well remember that
I'm glad and the sergey's well
you help us to build plants that you
feel that you know that's it people
preserve it serve these memories and
this is good and we tend our safety
thank you once with mr. boot around we
talk to what is happening in the world
and how easy and how not easy it is to
be a politician because at one time the
politician will receive you in his
office will analyze it she would
synthesize it you know now you cannot be
feeling of the masses because in the
millions will not have a daya I came to
the conclusion and this was something we
prize for you my honor is yours J it is
a piece of a thousand the Sun is near
seven and ninety eight of these
greetings came from the United States
and what letter serious buttonhole with
yours but really to do where we
published book together good idea
you know who useful now we can publish
another book match it what what is very
interesting Solange it this is happening
tada Couture is within which these
tendencies if we understand them
properly with a median of some exactly
now we have what we do in this world and
where is the place to you were still not
it is not
that's the podium is a big to approach
because people are situation is America
going to cheat us is it really so yeah
Lucas crying and we are opening our
power so we are ready America
all of a sudden American County will
give somebody poison it it will just
derail it for decades it's pushing the
pole that happens we have a mantra cheat
I and I get some information and I read
it out alleviated the most the world who
can we trust to can you believe what
Michelle tells you what now today so
that's what that Juliet that or the
intruder would just mean yet but
somebody who doesn't want to change the
passaggio anything she makes the
registers to a forensic statements right
and if you scratch the surface
everything has remained as before well
it's happening in the sky yeah but it
seems to me
Shawn sub L is it chances Navi Shh I'm
suing you today we never yeah this
turning point this watershed will forget
all you people better prepared for it
Electrical HHS came home and also
everybody mr. Warren yes and you I know
mr. Krasny please all the corners
discernment to ization together now it's
one sounds a chinois
is defeated convert well of course I
know yeah but I do see the motor
civilization and let everybody do it we
pray to the God that he wants to know
miss I don't breathe us here well yes oh
yes here sitting in another chair so we
can see each other better and quietly
and somebody who is wise after all that
experience and he said mr. Gorbachev why
are you so
afraid of convergence in simple question
and right without this variance of our
evolution of ecology and what it created
in life short or if but home trees lost
Namie he captured the fermi-level Africa
if don't even say what deformed us what
we had to live through I mean the
impulses were very strong the freedom
equality Olivia who passed away he was a
attention to the simple man yes they
were Tony Avella his defense without
that then capitalism could not have
mobilized its resources du net wasn't
allowed to deal with it let me DTAC that
that's what what we can do for people we
had to counter right is known as
regulation know everybody is doing it
but the way we do it is wrong but if you
do it changes in in our groups that's
normal and and so on and so forth well
it is one civilization and with all our
differences they are a sneaky especially
that come up and I think the divergence
is address it is a basis for discussions
and perhaps brings the higher level of
knowledge that what and so
yeah with us all right would like for
you less you to invite you to cooperate
awesome let's of solidarity when you
might but mostly thank you mutual
understand what understanding this is
the word that you bended about for
decades nobody really believed in it but
now we can give it a real sense if a
human you're watching approach M we I am
very glad and we all feel power into the
hands of the United States and potential
circles in what is happening now as
least before we welcome
different forms of course we retain
Federation of exchanges we seen as the
delegates get instead of white a logical
argument English boys we see more and
more desire to seal temple to search and
this is the most cumulative turning
point
no worried and if we rejoined us never
hasta you're just where your movie with
americium cut your integrity here attack
you or follow our choice you must see
how to change and how to transform it
will try to blast nice to the modelers
see Mr Tan is how to protect when you
ruin is social justice also we tried to
culture
ah Washington yeah don't worry and in
general that actually period Americans I
think Americans facing such problems
sisters you know any problem if we are
to talk about problems perhaps that
different okay yeah I told the president
and I keep telling you but mesh right
perhaps pressure the solid you in is
weak this is not serious
how can you talk about we could position
offices somebody on the leadership who
is right if your striker is moving hands
the beam and the instability changes
this is that it is serious undertaking
fundamental undertaking it's moving
ahead we are changing a political system
new economic system problem within the
framework certain real conditions in our
country and take into account our
experience and our economy yet then he
wouldn't talk it is not it then you
would away it is an America the wages in
Germany you not you might get blue with
you let you but it will come our way
otherwise if we are chemically double
somebody else's model this will not work
with the parish walk if you die we know
this quite well that now what it means
yeah butcher sue oh boy who's got that
but I am very much afraid when people
say well let's offer this model well
know if if you don't have you cannot
subtract thought that yes yes reality
104 covers what I told my Sinatra fellow
the song before I arrived in in Moscow
moment yet nor it can awaken any speaker
to worry chrome here if there was no
indication whether it be amiss here in
Texas toast and no elation of
integration but I was using simple
language you up here come who you have
come over structure that come on here
who's afraid of it who is not afraid the
horse working is not afraid who's
producing well the market will only help
only in this waiting for government
handouts yes of course and to the heart
for that genuine yet well I will not
over with this free to do it he just
meant to somebody who spoke all right
after me were he was it preaching so
perhaps his sermon was more important
than my speech about the marketplace oh
yes oh yes well there you are
they are sir perhaps Oh perhaps so let's
split until when you deal you but on
Monday already this is the worst or the
session began truthfully to be able to
be here people we're in the at the dead
end when 100 deputies have spoken
started with discussion came to the
conclusion or may have to continue our
work were the government and the Richard
make certain Corrections what steps to
take and move forward
cerium yet whoever today Antoine the
discussion on this topic one of the
Americans with they just give you say
and do you know who I talked it was not
a president know told me well you know
were the market economy in market you
cannot be half pregnant that's how I say
yes I agree
at the same time before a child is born
you need nine months and with the market
economy is the same thing otherwise it
cannot pull out of the Tim mortar seven
months yes I didn't want that boy
Italian I wants to speed it up and you
week either so bill arena survey it's
it's a child and not a stillborn child
well you need time we would you make you
cream well market well the great
difficulty all my friends will tell me I
mean you can't go down any for the
Americans it's all simple mother talk
about the markets owners in all the
instruments and the whole infrastructure
of the market we are absolutely nothing
nothing for the market we have to create
eight the infrastructure for us is
speculation and speculation for you
here's the marketplace Stephanie those
me kept me busy
however you must keep a little notes how
we have to twists our brains turn that
we are taking these changes we would
like very much to be understood by our
people
and by others first of all my I would be
contrarian everything I'll be honest it
is we are not ready we are not mature
enough revolution the revolution
is in the mine - first of all and then
it can spread out
yabba-doo shorter but I thank you once
again I'm very glad to see you either we
have some personal contacts yeah and
with others what brings us together
hello mr. Gregory Peck who else
Aseema where did Bradbury who write
science fiction very wise which then yet
be free with the future and those who
had to stop the work to come here my UV
we believe is that any so it all my
favorite writers are here and what's
published in Southern Union I was able
to read so we have known each other for
quite some time
yeah sure and again alright thank you
name of my friends I welcome you once
again and I expect we'll have
cooperation this is very even
he has very important times great
responsibilities and we expect much but
and how we treat each other
much will depend over I thank you
[Applause]
yeah Polizzi said they not in connection
with our meeting I propose a toast that
was the way of me
will you miss the you let us be together
and understand each other
at this point the luncheon at the Soviet
embassy began we resumed our coverage a
little while later as members of the
audience begin to offer toasts to
President Gorbachev
[Music]
I was my name is Professor Lancia I am
an American economist I am American
citizen since 1931 so I think I deserved
but I was born in Russia and I love
Russia and I was engaged during the last
two days in a very interesting
discussion of conversion of a ruble you
know it has not only economic but also
symbolic significance if we can convert
ruble into dollar and back it is a
symbol that we understand each other
kind of intellectual convertibility is
as important naturally as economic
convertibility and a price was operative
for a best essay on that subject pretty
big prize I think all together Oh
together over forty thousand dollars yes
it depends how it translated
[Music]
and believe it or not
600 submissions were received 600 it was
quite a problem of processing them and
our Soviet colleagues in Moscow and we
here in United States worked hard and it
was reduced to 25 on a second stage and
then three Soviet economists and three
American economists slaved during her
last three days
choosing what are the best and as you
can imagine with discussion was kind of
a two sided we discussed with says but
we also discussed two economic problem
it was kind of slightly mixed but
finally we came to a conclusion it was
announced yesterday
telephones brought it to him
winners and we didn't know who may are
the signature will still be numbers and
it was very interesting there was
several Soviet economist and one of them
a young economist I understand very able
one you know her and an American
economist my student who is recognized
as a greatest authority on Soviet
economy and monetary system when we
called him up he was just absolutely and
I understand that madame vaviiova and
and one was a is I think a Russian who
works United Nations Addis Abeba
you see it was really covering who world
it will be published I understand
I hope where Soviet authorities in the
banks take into account what is
recommended in these essays but
different recommendation you know for
economist never can agree but much
agreement now I consider it is a model
symbolic occurrence where we can work
together and let us introduce not only
monetary convertibility in exchanges but
intellectual and general economic
cultural controllability I apologize for
taking your time
[Applause]
[Music]
mr. president mrs. Gorbachev mr.
president you were kind enough to refer
to me in you
very moving of memory mark
so I would like to take the opportunity
to
respond very briefly
I was particularly struck about the
comment you made about the century of
romance between our nation's
which means started down the road and
then something always happened I was
part of a period in which such an effort
was made
had remarkably effect in unifying the
American people
because liberals thought if the
administration in which I served wanted
an end of tension the movies little
tension wouldn't be so bad and
conservatives thought that if the
Soviets wanted an agreement it had to be
bad for us and so
it'd be neat
come to the fruition that we wanted
although many important initiatives
would take
I believe mr. president dead
the problem
of international peace it's the
overwhelming issue of our time
and you are here at a period which is
very rare in history in which many
factors of the international environment
are fluid at the same time
and there is therefore an opportunity
for leading statesmen
to create a new international order
short-sighted
Statesmen think only of the advantage of
their own country
realistic and farsighted statesmen know
that no serious agreement will be kept
by serious people unless it is perceived
to be of benefit to both of them
and it's therefore an application to
take into account
there's self-respect
ponder view of the other side
with the president in Canada you made a
comment that the new organization in
Europe should not be presented as a kind
of
dictation from the West I agree with
I think at the same time it is also
not up to the opportunity simply to go
through the numbers of all the familiar
negotiations
and I hope what I believe is
certainly the attitude of our president
and what I know from my conversations
with you has always been your attitude
and what was expressed in your questions
what kind of United States do you on
what kind of Soviet Union do we want and
above all
what kind of international order
[Music]
contributes to peace and progress
I have great confidence
in your approach mr. Fester
you can though as you pointed out
we have not always agreed on the
individual saluting
you don't need my agreement
I think however that really attitude
that you have shown and really historic
changes you have already proud that you
will certainly lead your country
as I hope our president believed our
country
towards an international order in which
we don't think of ourselves as
adversaries but in which in progressive
meetings we can plan more and more
what we can do together to achieve these
objectives thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president let's go up a chat
good to see you again let me assure you
that there are vast part of American
people
who reckon this initiative from
confrontation to on ruler competition to
cooperation
one concern that strikes me about this
notion of togetherness which is so
fundamentally sound in the plan that
you're initiating perestroika and
glasnost you and mr. Bush meet here
today the gap you represent
when eight of the human race 7/8 of
third world peoples its impact upon the
rest of the world it is clear that you
and this nation and perestroika will
leave us unable to engage in perestroika
of our own definition and the whole
world
and so as an orphan confrontation and
fear the collaboration and hope how do
you see the fan out of this a on our
crest for Middle East peace jet venture
to break that cycle of terror and pain
how does it manifest itself and in the
nap at aid in South and seven Africa and
how does joint venture manifests itself
for example in a space development
initiative rather than a space Defense
Initiative we become more secure and
less threatening one to the other
I miss them terribly impressed with the
idea of preparation and unity this
immediate the fan of the pen the tremor
stacks of the world the property abounds
and nuclear proliferation continues are
enlarged must be addressed rather
quickly because of you and mr. Bush end
up with a great agreement and we
certainly hope that that last take place
him in an impact a pen a pen the seven
eighths the room not in the meeting rest
him live in all of us thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
excuse me I've already stood up twice
and now that I should be seating to a
lady
but mr. president and mrs. Grammer chef
when I tell you I'm deeply honored I was
to be invited I'm deeply grateful my
mother was to be invited
particularly since she approaches her
94th birthday in October
was worth great
remembrance of all your kindness
hospitality that you showed us last
summer
we were being present at my concerts was
absolutely a thrill
I know it thrilled all my friends in
Texas
as I came to this gathering and I was
told that it was a Conclave of
intellectuals and I said oh my
how I became a member of this orgasm
group
and as I looked around the room to see
all of these exceedingly famous people
not only to me just as an American but
as I have found out to you also and to
your daughter being from the other side
of the world
I realized that
what you are trying to achieve and what
we tried to chew to achieve here in the
United States is to create
a monetary climate
enrich as your wonderful first lady mrs.
Gorbachev
has created the cultural foundation of
the Soviet Union
and is lending her efforts to try to get
private support from Soviet citizens
to be sure to safeguard the many
beautiful treasures
the 7th of May of this year 1990 marked
the 150th anniversary of the birth
of a very universally beloved man
Tchaikovsky
and some polls have been taken
not by
musicians and musicologists necessarily
but they were just at random all around
the world
in every country
in every type of nation
and
Tchaikovsky is one of the most beloved
composers
so for that we are very grateful
to Russia
the Soviet Union for preserving
these glorious masterpieces but also
what a great history of famous and
fabulous musicians you have given the
world you have enriched our world and
that is through the ethereal the
aesthetic all art is personal
we approach and recognize anything
artistically
through the emotions first and then the
intelligence if the intelligence is
behind the emotion the piece of art will
live so we know that all of the great
masterpieces all of the great glorious
performers that you the great country
of Russia and the Soviet Union
have given to the world is a great
blessing I know the president and mrs.
Bush was so enjoy hearing mr. pluck me I
played tomorrow night
at your return dinner that's wonderful I
want to tell you we pray for you
we pray for our president and we wish
you a very happy stay here in our
country thank you
[Music]
thank you I am NOT unknown quantity my
name is Sarah harder I am a women's
activist who has worked in the u.s.
women's movement for 10 years we
organized in the first two weeks in May
the first Soviet American women's summit
was determined to make the statement
that women who are half the creative
capacity of the human race will bring
that capacity to bear on the challenges
and problems of the decade ahead of us
we crafted in our summit meeting an
agenda which is called from disarmament
to daycare a woman's vision for the 21st
century we know President Gorbachev that
this agenda was delivered to you in
Russian in the Soviet Union and I have
brought copies of it today for you and
for mrs. Gorbachev who's been a strong
supporter of these issues
I thought the others present here might
like to know a quick rundown of our
points of what is important in the next
decade for women the first is to ensure
the full participation of women at all
levels of decision-making that's as much
our problem is your problem but we're in
it together the second is to implement a
comprehensive test-ban free
to demilitarize our societies to convert
from military to socially responsible
societies to hearts destruction of the
environment and to implement as you have
proposed a global action plan for
environmental restoration to respect
human rights and to recognize that human
rights include women's rights and they
also include economic political rights
for all people but well I must put into
practice the non-intervention principles
of international law that we must
promote cultural exchanges and support
the United Nations it's a fairly short
list that represents a comprehensive
vision again I offer this to you with
the gratitude for your leadership of
over 100 US women's organizations and
the 26 Soviet women leaders who joined
us
[Music]
your excellency thank you for your
comments about my sermon that followed
yours on television in your country last
week I would like to add this sentence
as my special line for mr. Gorbachev
- Oh Leah Remini Rahul yet to show Leah
Ludi us to Utah
[Music]
and broke a little bit of us here toldja
[Music]
as president my
I add my small brief word of welcome to
you
this is Gorbachev and tell you of my
pleasure and being part of this assembly
also my pleasure and that my little
friend and colleague Andrew Kissinger
and I were singled out in your
extraordinarily interesting early
remarks my particular pleasure that
while you've had to correct professor
Kissinger on his past errors you left me
entirely exempt from any of my own that
is a comparison which you will have no
doubt
I applaud let us also learn from you
that there are similar lessons for our
own economy and that absolutes do not
work here either
capitalism as we know it would not have
survived except as we've had over the
years a substantial infusion of social
controls and civilized social behavior
this has been true of farmers it has
been through trade unions or trade
unions that is true of the old the sick
we have a financial system which is
bolstered only and I use the word
advisedly by the most expensive of
socialist activities
to make concessions in your direction
I hope without too much apology I hope
that we can recognize that this is
common to modern life through modern
economic life and that we can join
I do not suggest in a unity of systems
but in a healthy pragmatism that will be
good for us all thank you
[Music]
mr. president and mrs. Gorbachev
I represent a university which has been
in Washington for 201 years now but I've
been president of it for less than one
and so it behooves me to be brief
as part of the Washington commute I
would like to offer you my grandmother's
toast which went this way here champagne
to our real friends and real pain to our
sham friends may our nation's come
closer to friendship over many years to
come under your continued leadership and
that of our own President to our real
friends
[Music]
mr. president
I don't rise to give you any advice but
to sort of express some deep
appreciation to you for having brought
us back into history
for seven forty years we've looked
really outside here caught in the
straitjacket of ideology which had no
real reference to our times and I might
suggest it was sometimes sustained a
little bit by refugees with after
Hungarian Empire who were prepared to
maintain the balance of power and
tripartite relationships and other
matters of that kind the only it's not a
regret I some of us came here at risk
once you said you embody intellectuals
and there's very dangers for politician
in this country to be called AB
intellectual it's only to be intelligent
but you have to be very careful because
if you make a good judgment the others
who have as much intelligence but
haven't made that judgment will
immediately say you are an intellectual
at which point you're supposed to be
disqualified for any kind of practical
action in politics in Iran a feast which
they said you were not an intellectual
but you're intelligent so
[Music]
and the dollar and 1980 campaign we
suddenly came up someone did do it the
great concept if we didn't spend five
percent of our gross national product on
defense that there would be a window of
peril I think in 1985 well some genius
figured that if you figured your GNP and
your defense expenditures in rubles and
figured ours in rubles that we were all
right so under a ruble economy we were
safe
I thought if you converted into dollars
we weren't safe and I took great
consolation and I've especially since in
that same year it was reported that 1
billion dollars our GNP came from
pickles and I suggested that the Regis
could get an agreement we would not
count pickles in our GNP and you not
count borscht in yours and we could drop
the base so the percent of GNP that you
spent on defense would be much higher
and you'd have a great consolation from
that relationship in any case thank you
for bringing us back into history it's
been a long way --then it's almost like
the under World War two and we start
over from that point with great thanks
to you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
I would like if I may on behalf of all
of us to offer to our host President
Gorbachev and to Raisa Maxima our very
best banks for this meeting for this
very interesting and helpful reunion and
also I would like to drink raise a
maxima and what she is doing to bring
women in her country into perestroika
and the new world of the 90s
[Music]
see where
[Music]
Lester all of you skyrest lava to say to
all of you
don't place lava some very warm words
that have been temperature words of
thanks for this meeting about you for
Rama Galbraith that Africa where the
same extent were come very close to a
seminar because of professor Gabriel in
[Music]
wanted very much to rush into the fray
[Music]